ladies and gentlemen Rodney Dangerfield
nice tuxedo huh underneath torn
underwear but first like to say thanks
the people here at the academy they've
been very nice before the show they
introduced me to a lovely young lady
they told me if I need anything she's
here to help me and I should be with me
until the show is over very nice and
just when I needed a send her home no
that's just cute stuff that's all I do
but I'm here tonight present the award
for makeup and make them as important I
mean in movies everybody wants to look
good you know and who always wins the
award the guy who creates the ugliest
creature there is now people don't want
to look good makes him feel better but
my wife for now had her face lifted my
luck there was one just like it
underneath
mr. joke good joke that's some kid I'm
not married not married no but where was
our makeup no make it was important well
the last week I'm in a girl makeup
didn't help her at all
I mean his girl was ugly how are they
when she goes to the bank they turn off
the cameras
I mean ugly she went to a plastic
surgeon here to the tail
hungry you kid why when she walks the
room mice jump on chairs
you know I I take it all back looks are
not that important it's underneath what
counts old debt that's what's important
that looks but how many times you take a
walk in the street you see a tall
handsome man walking arm-in-arm at a
short fat ugly girl I never saw dr. Java
see that I never saw that
I will get the reward now for the best
achievement in makeup the nominees are
the clan of the cave bear Michael G
Westfall and Michelle Burt I tell you
you gotta watch out for those single
bars
the fly Chris Wallace you know and stuff
in between now I know why they invented
the fly swatter
legend Rafa and Peter Rob King this
reminds me the last time I quote an
escort service
and the winner for the biscuit even
makeup is Chris Wallace is Stephen
dupois for the fly
I'd like to thank my director David
Cronenberg my producer mr. producer head
Stewart Kornfeld
the best makeup crew I've ever worked
with Stefan and the person that for me
made the makeup really work Jeff
Goldblum thank you very much I I would
like to thank the makeup crew on
location Margaret Becerra Donald mowett
the entire CWI crew and again mr. Jeff
Goldblum for doing such an incredible
performance being buried under five
pounds of grotesque nature thank you
Jason for your patience